this is my favorite clip of the week
possibly of the month maybe of 2023 so
far
you're gonna just sit down for this one
okay
if I told you
that my racial background was a
sword
what would you think you'd think
something's not right you'd think oh boy
David Pacman sir the wheel is spinning
but the hamster is dead you would think
something was very wrong with me well
that is exactly the word that Newsmax
guest Vernon Jones used during a segment
on Newsmax about when Joe Biden said I'm
a white boy but I'm not dumb or
something along those lines you you have
to see this
uh Vernon Jones
oh God I think I might just play it and
not even explain it and I'll explain it
later okay here's Vernon Jones telling
us what are the three races
what are the three races this is what he
said yesterday he said I'm a what at
this church I'm a white boy but I'm not
stupid Vernon I mean yeah let me drop
back for a second first of all Jason my
good friend uh being Latino is no race
they were throwing three races monogor
conquer sword and negroid oh my god oh
dear God there are three races folks
mono gourd
caucusord and negroid okay
do you know where this comes from
um as Dave Weigel pointed out our friend
Dave Weigel this is not a random guy
this is Vernon Jones who was endorsed by
Trump in 2022. he thankfully lost his
primary
here's what Vernon Jones is talking
about there's this old
1780s race idea that there are
essentially three races those three
races are
caucasoid
and negroid or as it was
originally called Ethiopian this is from
the 1780s uh it comes from the gottengen
school of History it was then later
developed further and it became one of
these racist ideologies during the age
of colonialism okay so it's insane that
Vernon Jones
particularly as a black man is saying
this is the reality about race but it's
extra insane that he's mangling beyond
recognition the names of these races
a sword what on Earth I mean it
sounds like uh it sounds like when when
little boys play swords if you know what
I'm talking about it's insane let's play
it one more time absolutely my favorite
clip maybe of the year so far Vernon I
mean were there let me drop back for a
second first of all Jason my good friend
drop back to contextualize caucusword
for us uh being Latino is no race
there's only three races
sword and negroid oh God
well it it you couldn't write this stuff
but liberals create this whole new class
or a new race called Latinos they are no
race right and it is it is very clear he
did say that that Hispanics are more
diverse in their thinking than
African-American not diverse in where
they from come from as a matter of fact
Spaniards have nothing to do with
Mexicans and they all speak the same
language but again well I think
God I think Spaniards have something to
do with Mexicans if you study the
history of uh of the the Spanish why do
you think that that Spanish is spoken in
most but not all Central and South
American countries now of course now in
Mexico the population is uh many you
have a lot of multi-racialism in Mexico
which is folks from Spain who then
um uh had kids with those populations
that were already in what is now Mexico
but what has has anyone ever heard a
dumber analysis of whatever this is
create this race if you and made it
unique based on you speaking uh Hispanic
or speaking I speak Hispanic that's
exactly right so our Spanish yeah so
let's be clear about that too this is a
verbal ink plot this is just a mess Joe
Biden stands in front of a black college
like Morehouse and Spelman he says that
and the reason why black businesses
aren't as successful as whites is
because they don't have lawyers and they
don't have accountants that is racist
that shows how naive he said it is and
to say he's 89 saying that how about
when Joe wasn't 80 when Joe didn't want
black people uh to go in his
neighborhood and go to school I didn't
see it Carla Harris said so Joey has a
long history of bigotry Joe has a long
bigotry all right anyway I want you to
email me let me know if there was a if
if you were running a 5k or playing
intramural hockey are you going to be on
monogord or do you prefer to be on what
I believe is the winning team the Kaka
swords I know I know where I'm going
with this one folks you let me know one
of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zippix toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below